boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake I'm
very excited to still be at Coe Fez the
Congress on the future of engineering
software with our second annual
partnership with them we are very
excited to now have the president of Coe
Fez Institute
Vincent Caprio hello thank you some
Allen I've loved being with you the last
two cycles here at the event and so many
of our sponsors and speakers just you're
a great interviewer you really not
handle things I'm very honored that you
said that thank you and it's this place
is loaded with it's a big brain trust
this you know we've had some epic
conversations that people that have sat
here
Vince's background is awesome not only
she's been the president of Co Fez
destitute he's also Technology historian
and a technology event producer over the
last 30 years and the conversations that
we've had he's just been dropping lots
of wisdom on me let's talk about your
life let's talk about this journey how
did you become who you are when you were
younger and it slowly builds you up my
grandfather was a civil engineer
my grandfather believed in education my
grandfather put himself through night
school and he graduated from NYU it took
him seven years my grandfather believes
so much in education that he put his
other seven siblings through college one
of them became a cardiologist
three of them were teachers so another
engineer so my grandfather believed so
much in education having you know been
from Italy and then my father was my
father was in the Korean War and came
out of the Korea and he graduated from
Seton Hall and accounting and my grant
my father even in the earliest days of
unit UNIVAC loved computers and he
started working with computerization
when he went to the IRS in the 50s and
so my father from an early age talked
had me go into you know the computer
room at the
IRS and the tapes and the whole bed and
so he worked for the IRS for 40 years
and I then went off to Villanova in 1975
to study accounting and Mis and data
processing and I loved all that and
while it was at Villanova I've read in
Fortune magazine and Wall Street Journal
about these two fellows in the Silicon
Valley jobs and Wozniak and then I said
gee this is really cool that someday you
can have a computer on your desk and
then I got out of Villanova and I went
to work for the IRS and I was working
you know what the big mainframes the IBM
mainframes and then so I you know got
involved with really looking at the the
mainframes and then the minis and the
yellow size and the VAX machines and
then in 1981 when IBM introduced the
first PC I went out and bought one for
$4,400 and I was recently telling
somebody that story they said $4,400 you
bought it an IBM PC and you were making
$15,000 in 1981 or 82 that'd be like
spending $20,000 now and they said I
never really thought about it because
when I heard about the IBM PC I really
wanted one and I had an 80 80 80 86 chip
and you know I really embraced
technology so and what was really great
is my grandfather and my father loved
history and I loved history so I started
making sure I understood who the Giants
and the history of technology you know
one of the first things I remember
reading was about IBM and how IBM in
1959 worked with ADP elektra ADP you
know most do you get a paycheck
you know it was called it's called ADP
now but it was called advanced data
processing in 1959 they did a
partnership and that was the first time
people got automated paychecks and and I
had known about that and by 1968 when I
was in fifth grade so I always looked at
the history of it my fifth grade project
was on computers that I won the science
fair in fifth grade for and of course I
won the science fair in seventh grade
sixth seventh and eighth grade so I love
science but I always loved the history
of science it was always interesting for
me to read the biographies of the men
and women that you know brought us this
technology and I and so it's really been
cool in my 40 years is that I've seen
this whole revolution you know I was
there when when you know Gates and Paul
Allen you know had Microsoft and I
bought Microsoft when they went public
in 86 I was a stockholder so I always
followed everything you know I followed
Wozniak and Jobs and Apple and you know
it's really been interesting to live the
history of it you know and it's it's
very rewarding to be able to explain the
history of it you know to some of the
younger people that are in their 20s now
yeah yeah there's so many things that
you brought up there that are crucial
first is the the grandpa it's crazy that
he worked to put the other seven
siblings yes through college as well yes
because when when when you when you
realize that when the mind is so young
that it has the potential to absorb
stimuli and then become at another whole
level of understanding reality a higher
level more powerful level that's why
it's so important to get at young age
these these really powerful knowledge
--is
you know it is sisters because you know
those people that have come up to me and
and I've spoken out over I've spoken at
hundreds of conferences I've spoken at
NIST and DoD and I've spoken at
cybersecurity conferences sponsored by
the FBI and obviously I've spent I've
spoken at over 100 colleges and
universities and many times somebody
we'll get done and we'll go to the
cocktail hour and the student said will
yourself made and I said no I'm not
self-made know who you know I said my
grandfather and father made me
I'm not self-made they it was and no one
gave me money but no they provided the
platform and they provided for me to
understand that I needed an education
and my father and grandfather it's
interesting my grandfather and father
told me Christmas is for women and
children
my grandfather believes so much that
every Christmas my grandfather gave me
two gifts a $25 savings bond for me to
have for when I went to college and a
book mm-hmm so I never received like
toys and things like that
it was here's a book and here's a bond
so that's what you would say your
self-made you started out at the IRS
making $10,000 a year no no I'm not
self-made my family made me my
grandfather and my father's belief my
grandfather father used to say you know
America is all this opportunity you are
what you're perceived to be yeah there's
this notion that we stand upon the
shoulders of giants a lot of the time
that the giants are within our family
right he helped us we get to where we
are in a lot of time then you read all
those books and the Giants are also in
those books and so those components are
really critical to your growth and then
as you as you ended up indicating
there's this there is a strong desire
for you to read about what Wozniak and
Jobs we're doing and what Paul Allen
Bill Gates were doing and when you did
that you really started absorbing what
technological revolution was happening
and so this is this this is this
critical notion that for young people
that to be able to really find these
sources of the
most signal during time periods and the
least noise though the ones that are
ramping up you know who are the ones
that are driving the synthetic biology
age or the ones driving the neuroscience
and AI neural network age the cloud
computing age the engineering software
age who are those drivers latch on to
them read about them hang out with them
do all these things that will then drive
you to best understand the transitions
that we go through then it's also
interesting that from from this
perspective of Technology history you've
really been around like you said you
were young but you saw when paychecks
became automated right and that and now
all the way to to cryptocurrencies now
so the so now you're really good at
explaining this technology history why
has technology history in your eyes just
been something that you know even that
you're giving us example 20 year olds
when you're hanging out with us right
you know we're just like jaw dropped
listening to you well you know and it's
speaking at these colleges universities
say this student is 22 years old I know
that they've been on the internet their
entire life now look I'm 62 do you
realize all my friends none of us were
on the Internet until Netscape came with
the browser okay and it was unbelievable
revolution because one day there's this
browser and we've heard about the
internet and we might have friends that
you know got onto the World Wide Web
I mean look at it most of these younger
people don't know what www so I was at a
time that people would say what's your
website on my website is World Wide Web
Vincent Caffrey org
so could you imagine when I first got my
website instead of saying www Vincent
Caprio org I'm saying World Wide Web
it's a free org so then one day we have
a search engine and what's it six months
everyone's on the Internet okay
and so it was that adoption was that
quick yes this was 95 9 94 to 95 and so
pcs at home ok
it went from 20% market penetration to
by the end of the decade everyone had a
PC everybody had a device laptop and at
the same time the convergence of the
browser and then AOL letting you get
online and you know well within two
years have thirty five million users
that's why they got to be the largest
company they brought out Time Inc so
think about it before 90 early 94 I'm at
home using that IBM and it's not even my
croissant Windows 95
there's no GUI in it that's another
thing I use terms like GUI nobody knows
what that means
graphics user interface was brought to
us by Apple products Windows 95 windows
was all text driven I'm at home in 1992
you're working on a laptop it's all text
driven there's no icons you know you
know you push the thing and even to this
day my daughter laughs I hit print you
know I don't even I cannot for the print
so all of a sudden the convergence of
now you can go on the internet with AOL
now you have a browser now everybody's
on the Internet and if they're in a chat
room
there's I want to be in fantasy baseball
I mean in fantasy Volvo oh my gosh I can
go on espn.com and look at the score I
don't have to like stay up until 11:25
to watch the local station to see if the
master Yankees won or if the Red Sox won
you know
you yeah it all happened so you go from
not being able to use the box to the box
being extremely intelligent the box you
know looks like with me Vincent Capra
next thing I know I figured I want to
find every person with my name in the
world so I'm like hey wow man there's
like 20 people the exactly the same name
I'm sending them emails hey I'm Vincent
Gabriel from you know you know Boston on
this I'm that I'm there you know it's
kind of cool to think all of a sudden
and then the democratization of it
you're communicating with people all
over the world and all over the United
States it was really cool time it would
these these little the pockets of wisdom
that you're shutting these awareness
expansions for us is that you know when
so many people are coming online you're
you're able to then query the internet
with whatever the the question is like
what was the score of the game or what's
the weather like tomorrow you can now
get these data points in without needing
to the send message through instant
messenger to someone else across the
world in in in like that rather than
needing to wait for a paper to arrive
and this is this is a very important
advancement time period how did a AOL
lose thirty five million users that
sounds crazy that they blew that
opportunity well and so then when they
aquinnah they acquired a time warner it
was the largest deal in the history of
deals and what had happened is it had to
do with and most people who don't
remember if you had a o L you know you
had that was dial-up so you so you would
and there was a noise and you do you
know your mouth oh yeah you heard it
yeah so what happens called you just
know you finally got a DSL line you
didn't need a o L anymore yeah you got a
Dubai DSL line at your house you didn't
need an AOL account anymore you can just
you know go directly with somewhere else
and that was it their their business
then they thought that they could
maintain those thirty five million
people that were paying like ten or
twelve dollars a month those think they
would bill you every month on a credit
card ten twelve dollars with no twenty
dollars a month they think it was so you
know every month twenty dollars twenty
dollars but then one day he didn't need
them
so everybody canceled listen see as fast
as they went up they came down because
nobody needed them anymore you know
where what were people using instead of
AOL at that time then well they would
just go to a DSL line at home and then
they would use Yahoo an email address
they didn't need to because yahoo it's
free
yeah and then of course gmail came out
and it's free I mean think about it you
were paying a well for an email okay so
yes for 30 years of doing technology
event producing yes teach us about what
you've been producing and why those
conferences have been so crucial for
people to get so you know all the
conference's that I've been the Event
Director of they're dealing with
emerging technologies so the emerging
technologies when I started they were
talking about digital printing you know
with IBM we were talking about moving
from mainframes to minis to then PCs and
networked pcs and then eventually the
obviously access to the Internet and the
Netscape then Windows 95 and you pretty
much it was very easy to communicate
with people with the speed on the
internet and then messaging and then you
know you get to 2007 and you know all
these baby boomers find out that they
don't have to pay a fee to somebody to
do a class reunion there's some kid from
Harvard who wanted to meet girls and his
friends now we can go on Facebook and
find all our old girlfriends from high
school and we don't have to pay somebody
to find them so next thing you know
every baby boomer you know within about
a six-month period is now on Facebook
and they're communicating with friends
from since they're ranked it had art
from a kindergarten I mean Facebook you
know for all the criticism and the
privacy issues let's be realistic I mean
a guy like
me I I met I got on and my first day I
got 2,000 people I thought about every
person that I knew K through 12
I graduated from Villanova I thought
about every person I knew from Villanova
I thought about every person that from
my MBA program and I thought about every
person I worked so I obsess about for 20
straight hours and I had two thousand
people and then the next day I had four
thousand people the next thing I know
I'm talking to somebody I went to
kindergarten with it really what is cool
I mean look and a lot of baby boomers go
off to complain about it come on I mean
it brings you back to when you were
younger and you're communicating with
somebody that you would have never
communicated with I mean I was the
president of my high school class and we
had a 40th year reunion and when we had
a 10 year reunion and a 20-year reunion
30-year reunion yeah it goes through all
these hoops to try to find people well
one of my one of my girlfriends she was
already retired so I said to her she was
how are we gonna find everybody so you
know think about this I took out the
high school yearbook I put everybody in
an Excel spreadsheet that's the use of
technology I then I emailed er the
spreadsheet and then she takes out the
spreadsheet and she started she says
what am I gonna find everybody just type
their name and search in Facebook did
you know that every person I went to
high school with all 200 people were on
Facebook and and the ones that weren't
on Facebook she's here the following
people are on Facebook where do you
think they already said looked in
Twitter no any of you know I said
tragically is what you're gonna do take
their name and type in obit and every
other person was dead so they came up as
an obit and so 20 percent of my class of
200 people 40 of them had passed on but
how did we finally passed on we typed
their names in on Google and we write we
type in a bit and there were bitumen so
think about that
we tracked everyone down from Facebook
or Google
yeah it's with the power of the Internet
right right and then and then what you
do then talk about this then
call my call my web designer I put up a
high school reunion page called GoDaddy
that costs nothing I have somebody
GoDaddy accounts and web sites the kid
puts up the GoDaddy nowadays it's
nothing they the kid doesn't in a
friggin an hour now I have my high
school reunion page up and you know you
just you go to Facebook and you you put
the link on it and next thing you know
you know 20 people are signed enough you
know I mean and for me as an event
producer then I had a link back to
PayPal to collect the money you know how
hard it was for me to do my 30th reunion
you're collecting the money you're
mailing me a check I got everybody to
pay me before ya there this this brings
up a really interesting trajectory so it
goes these technology events that you're
producing and directing there they take
us all the way back to you know 30 years
ago when technology would when your
reunions are so much more difficult to
cry and execute all the way until now
where they're just so much easier to get
done we're much more easier to bring
communities of people that either so
there's really definitely this just in
many ways a trend of in of in this and
this will light that you shedded it it
is it is a beautiful way of bringing
people together now I identified this
these last 30 years and identifying this
this this exponential technology curve
in being here and seeing these people's
you know these young people like me the
college students that you go and speak
in front of when when we're just so
shocked about technology history well
when there's when when students today
don't don't don't even necessarily know
about Wozniak and jobs and how they put
things together for us that why is that
so important why is technology history
such a crucial awareness expansion for
young I think it's so important because
of
how productive its man our lives and
it's not debatable that it's a bad thing
see unfortunately there's a lot of
negative people that leave
philosophically it's hurt us and that's
not true you have to look at the
enormity you have to look at it in a 360
view you can't take bits and pieces of
the pie and say well this sliver is a
privacy issue and blah blah blah no if
you look back of the last 30 years its
enormous
how much meant it's made our lives so
much easier and I also contend which a
lot of people say is not true
I believe it's made us be able to
communicate better now I grew up
communicating with people without the
devices and without Facebook and without
LinkedIn however when I stopped
communicating with people when I got out
of college it is really cool that I can
communicate with 16,000 people on
LinkedIn and 5,000 people on Facebook
and there's people that I haven't talked
to since 1968 and they go on LinkedIn
and they see my profile and they push a
button and I get a message and it says
you know I went to I went to fifth grade
in 1968 with the guy with the same name
as you you know and he was a real he was
a real big talker and he was above a
it's currently crazy is the same name as
you and then I typed back but and that's
me and he's like get the blank out of
here but and they get to see your entire
hit history what's happened and that's
why they say it they say it's hurt
communication skills for younger people
and for people I fundamentally disagree
because I wouldn't have been
communicating with these people anymore
you know and some of these people that
are introverted weren't able to
communicate without this you know for
them to write back to me on LinkedIn you
know the shy girl or the shy guy you
know I was extroverted and I still am
but for them to communicate with me I've
gotten into some really great
communications with people that you know
I really never talked to much in 1971
was a freshman in high school and next
thing I know you know the the you know
the the the woman is talking to me about
this and that and you know I'm a diet
I'm myself a diabetic so now I'm sharing
the point that I'm a diabetic well look
at all that it really builds up a
community of people and my father's
generation they didn't have it and he
got out of high school and say it's 1975
he's not talking to any of these people
you know so and I was talking about this
the other day say my father in 1919 55
1965 1975 1980 America was not that much
different in the workforce and with
people in 1955 65 75 1980 everything
changed with Wozniak and and and jobs
the next thing you know they forced IBM
with that PC as we earlier said then the
80s changed with the whole PC revolution
so what I said that this country was the
same for you know he had the war and
then in 45 you know from 45 to 55 there
was a lot going on you know the Russians
you know we found that the Russians had
nuclear weapons in 49 so let's get the
55 Eisenhower America because of the LAT
because of where we were in technology
it was basically the same place and the
way we communicate it but once again
people start it with those PCs and they
had pcs at home and the next thing you
know Andreessen and Netscape and their
it just opened everything up yes on to
you know the web and then what you just
mentioned there I wanted to get I wanted
to get us to get to is that you not only
have a technology history background you
have an overall history right right and
especially a focus on the last hundred
years of United States history and
within this last period of history we've
seen crazy things we talked about this
on the socioeconomic status level that
we see things like GDP continuing to
increase over the last 40 50 years
meanwhile median male income stagnant
Brett what's going on right as the 1%
with this technology boom just getting
extremely wealthier meanwhile the
average American families are continuing
to struggle so why don't we talk about
your all-seer synthesis on the well yeah
and so if you look back say in 1965 so
the Great Society program started in
1964 under President Johnson he
recognized after you know President
Kennedy had this vision and Johnson
carried it out after his assassination
of President Kennedy and he got elected
in 64 so the Great Society program comes
in and they recognized finally that 20%
of our of our people were impoverished
then they said that we had another 60%
were middle class and those the top 20%
and of the 1% of the top one percent is
the upper class but there was a really
an upper middle class and a middle class
so now fast-forward the clock you know
50 years later we still have the same
20% impoverished and we have a lot of
entitlement programs to help the
harvest where there were people when I
was a boy in 1965 you know I'd go into
New York City I'd look through the train
you you saw really poverty so we've
helped a lot of the 20% but now what's
happened the next 60% of people they
don't have $1,000 to fix their car they
are living paycheck to paycheck so
income inequality is it is true there's
no doubt about it
and and actually who's benefited is
people that are involved in information
let's be candid here so it's it when you
talk about educated you're you've become
educated but you became educated in
technology I mean a person that became
educated and how to work in a steel mill
or a coal mine that's not what that
didn't work out okay there's a
retraining right you know so the so that
the students that had an opportunity to
get involved in a technology society
benefited and unfortunately we have too
many people that didn't embrace the new
economy and that's really and now and
now we have this eek in income
inequality and you know there's so many
American cities that are like flint in
Worcester and and Dayton Ohio and Gary
Indiana where you know if they needed to
hire 5,000 people you know to like you
know you see Facebook has you know all
these big data centers well if you put a
data center in those places and they had
to hire 5,000 people there's not gonna
find 5,000 people to go into the diner
Center Facebook have put a data center
in bridgeport how are you gonna hire
5,000 people were they going to come
from and this is why well you know
whether it's Cambridge Mass or the
Silicon Valley a Research Triangle Park
are Austin or certain other technology
you know Seattle you so all the
technology
stirs the economic have done well and if
you're not in a technology cluster but
the people who live in technology
clusters have been educated into this
technology yeah yeah and this
there's also another so there's a social
fabric issue as well in terms of the way
that we've we've highlighted and propped
up conspicuous consumption and not
extended our inclusive fitness out to
the global village and and that is
that's something that I think we're
changing as well you and I could talk
for such long periods of time about
history and technology history and I'm
really excited to have you back on the
show sure sure
let's wrap on qoph as so the conference
on the future of engineering software
this is our second annual partnership
thank you and we want to be with you
forever
we do too I really do you've done such a
great job interviewing our keynote
speakers and you know we've had keen you
from Microsoft and Facebook and Dell and
it's just been wonderful and this is
this was the big thing as Vince did an
incredible job at bringing Co fest to
Silicon Valley and making sure that
we're we positioned right here next to
Facebook having Microsoft Facebook della
sponsors having their cutting-edge
speakers here this is one of the ways to
really birth in organ there's so many
young people here now this is a really
powerful way dough to rebirth an
organization powerfully moving forward
what is your synthesis on both the state
of engineering software in the future of
engineering software this is a really
cool brain trust that the co fess has a
I'm so up to mr. bout the future because
you know I the first time I heard about
say VR you know it was like it seemed
like a science fiction movie and then 30
years ago when I heard about AI and I
remember hearing about machine learning
I I was like no how can that be have
they gonna have software to pick up what
you're saying and it just seems so
remote but
it is it's been developed it's being
used and it's only gonna get better
it's it's like the cars the car from
1965 was the first year they had
seatbelts it just got better and better
and better
it's only gonna get better and better
and better because the men and women
that are coming out of schools and or
start using these products they're
starting in a different starting point
then say anyone my age so there are so
much more advanced you know with the
technology it's it's like taking a
shower in the morning for them it's not
some big deal for them to do so I'm just
my last couple this is my third cough as
I just can't believe what you see and
what some of these younger people are
been able to do yeah yeah the the
current state of extremely young people
being able to pick what they want to
learn and learn it like it is their
passion and having access that
information is so crucial in what we've
been able to highlight in the interviews
from the conference the state of
engineering software is just blowing up
and it's so beautiful to see that
because it's applicable to and and you
know my message that I'd like to leave
with everyone as a person that's been
involved with emerging technologies for
30 years I have to say it I said it
before and I know I'm repeating myself
technology has really done wonderful
things in America and the world and I
really a take it to heart that when
people think that we're not at we're
less productive and we've had some
trade-off you know there's people that
are negative that say it's the devil
then I heard the same thing about gates
like 25 years ago Microsoft is Microsoft
down my butt it's like and now you know
Facebook this uncle Burke hit the same
thing about photography yeah it's really
you know look this country has brought
all the technology advances
this world I mean you take a look what
changed our country the interstate Road
Act of 1956 we put these interstates
everywhere technology gave us as those
interstates and all the transportation
systems are helping our from technology
and now lastly the last mile they're
doing digitalization of the water
industry which is important and
technology is going to help clean the
environment technology is not destroying
the environment and that's like I said
it's only positive you know it's all
positive
yeah there's there's a lot of nuance and
I'm really happy that that you're
providing us with this little big
history perspective on on the on on the
role of of the evolution of humanity
Vince thank you so much Alan thank you
bro we love you here too man Superman
thank you everyone thank you minion we
greatly appreciate it we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
let us know what you're thinking about
technology history about Co Fez Co Fez
links below also stimulations links are
below support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in also
go and build the future manifest your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon